today on our show Kevin is off doing
Kevin [ __ ] in the world so today it's me
and a special guest to break down all
the news out of Star Wars Celebration
Orlando so come on back
[Music]
hello everybody today a sermon on Batman
I am your host mark barnard next to me
special guest David Collins Star Wars
expert who was on scene on the site down
and dirty in Orlando got all of the
[ __ ] [ __ ] to tell us everything that
happened everything to be missed
everything we couldn't see from the
Internet's so tell me is this how many
celebrations was this for you I don't
even know the number at this point but
as a host it's been 10 years well
actually before that I was working at
Lucas and I was working on a bunch of
Star Wars video games and I was demoing
those at celebrations before that so
probably I don't know eight or nine of
these things you know just talking about
Star Wars and I will I will say that
they just keep getting bigger and bigger
and bigger and of course you know Lucas
though himself said that this would
broke all the records with over 70,000
people in attendance out of four days
all from one franchise you know and it
was it was it was massive you know and
they really brought out all the big guns
for this one you know I mean there was
kind of no stone left unturned
especially for the 40th anniversary of
Star Wars me I mean they you know they
just had well everybody there I mean you
could get you saw the footage right I
mean yeah there it was crazy
that's not okay so before we get into
all of the awesome that happened yeah
tell me about your beginnings with Star
Wars like where did it begin free where
was where was the first time you
remember seeing it what was your first
reaction to it which movie was it right
yeah it's funny because Star Wars for me
I mean I'm at that age where you know it
came out when I was two so I don't even
remember the first one but I knew what
Star Wars was for I have memory of
seeing it so it should always been you
know and it was kind of a reality for me
as a kid in fact when I thought about
NASA I found out there was no sound in
space it was like well that's lame and
we got XY fighters what the hell you
know so like it's just always been a
part of my life and you know I was
seeing it as a kid but I started working
at Lucasfilm I mean when they all
started coming back in the 90s I was
getting obsessed with him as a college
student and I was read the books and
just really kicking out with my friends
playing all the games I started as an
intern right out of college at Skywalker
Ranch and then started working on and
literally you know work on dozens of
Star Wars video games and then
eventually got into hosting and you know
voiceover and I've done you know the
movies and video games and stuff
the voice-over artist and I've been
hosting Star Wars Celebration just
because it's my first love and I love it
you know so much you know I love a lot
of different franchises love Batman but
Star Wars is where I live
you know and so they just I'm lucky
enough for them to keep bringing me back
to be there that's awesome now for the
kids at home how does one score an
internship at Skywalker Ranch great
question because I highly recommend it
if you can do this I highly recommend it
no I just was really focused on what I
wanted to do and this was kind of early
internet days in fact I actually had to
snail mail Wow printed out letters of
recommendation with essay questions and
yeah and I had to have stamps and I like
a resume paper 9 d 9 d Wow but yeah that
was you know I was going on their
website and found that stuff and I just
really really got lucky I mean you know
there's a whole convergence of [ __ ] that
has to happen to quote Tom Kane a voice
actor but you know in order for you to
have a career doing and I got really
lucky but I just also pushed and pushed
and pushed but it's a great way for
people to get their foot in the door
it's a great way for companies to check
you out and I kind of hate to say
non-committal but in a trial period
right we're not what kind of almost
maybe not really paying you any real man
yeah exactly exactly so if you [ __ ] up
it's not like for real investment in
[ __ ] up yeah oh well you're the intern
did it but you can turn that nugget on
your resume into something awesome
because now you've got look at someone
your resume or wherever they decide to
intern and that's really the important
part even if they didn't hire you want
in fact I was at Skywalker Sound for an
intern shift for a year they didn't have
anything for me games edition did mmm
right so you just kind of kind of walk
through whatever door opens for you
right so that's awesome that's awesome
and so like you said this has been at
least ten celebrations maybe more as a
professional person yeah how many is a
fan I'm actually
well I'm feel like oh I've been through
all of them in the fan but every single
one of them but no I just I've always
been working them and I try and see as
much as I can but I didn't have the
money or resources when the first two
happened and so the third one I was an
already employee so I've always been
there in some sort of official capacity
but I always make time to see the show
floor and like
I mean it's like having a front row seat
to things that you want to see anyway
right you know and and if you can kind
of communicate that enthusiasm and just
be an amplifier for for the people in
the audience because I mean people are
going nuts you know it really is
front-row access to all the new sour
stuff now what I understand this is a
little bit like asking what your
favorite kid is right what is that
what's the best thing you saw this year
not on the stage not on a screen but
just like being in the floor being in
the zone what's the coolest thing you
saw man it really is hard I can name a
couple things there was a guy walking
around in Jedi robes with an oboe they
call himself oboe one and he was just
like playing all the John Williams stuff
while a is here and he'd be like that uh
you know you know that was pretty cool I
mean I saw just like snow white wookie
costume I saw people who were dressed
not as Princess Leia but the Princess
Leia or Obi one old Kenner action figure
with their arm stiff and they were
walking like this you know it's not kind
of crazy it's just on the creative stuff
but you know family's little kids I had
four nieces at the show they all dressed
up as Princess Leia and they went to
this heroines panel and they saw Daisy
Ridley's you know 20 feet in front of
them you know the coolest thing that I
saw there though well I don't know if
you want to get into it I said I got to
see John Williams do a full symphony
orchestra during shows anniversary and
nobody knew he was coming sure nobody
knew he was coming I have in a minute
journalists until this year for about 25
years yeah and almost every place I've
worked I've tried to get somebody to
score a John Wayne's interview and it is
the hardest [ __ ] thing to do like I
can get people in a room with Brad Pitt
I got people in a room with George
Clooney I get people in room with both
of them together in a hot tub but
getting an interview with John Williams
is like if I'm the [ __ ] Holy Grail
yeah I was lucky enough to work the red
carpet livestream for the force awakens
he was there and I said no matter what
happens I said to the producer can I
please try and get an interview with
John Williams and he was very gracious
and said I'm not doing
you know very modest from everything I
understand because I can't interview the
guy really modest guy and you know very
hard to get her here for sure but he was
there yeah one of the coolest pieces of
memorabilia I've ever seen in a room
filled with cool memorabilia was
interviewing Damon Lindelof a leaf or
something and he had like secured
there's a [ __ ] hatch from lost there
there's this is a shelf full of Emmys
but then against the wall was original
sheet music for the Imperial March oh
and I'm like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you for
having something so guy handwritten not
only was handwritten pricked it out like
score printed like on the session yeah
and like signed by John Williams and
some other letter from Lucas and like so
tell me about the other bold-faced names
who showed up to celebration this year
George Lucas showed up you know and in
an era of Disney to see George Lucas
show up and and be present for the 40th
anniversary standing with Kathleen
Kennedy and then Harrison Ford showed up
they kept all the seat I mean it didn't
leak at all Wow
no I how do you get all those people to
the Orlando Convention Center like even
through the door I just don't get it but
but they were all there Hayden
Christensen from the prequels was there
which is bananas that was like well this
was his first one in 15 years you know
and you know if you're you know I say
what you want about the prequels but you
know people grew up with those things
and there's mad love for those and it's
rare so when they announced that he was
coming because I now it said ahead of
time people went nuts and his autograph
line was sold out I mean people were
crazy one of the best things one of the
interviews from the Star Wars show asked
asked him a bunch of questions and said
I finally want to ask you this one
question how do you feel about sand and
I just heard about that I have any
material I have to check out the live
stream but I'm just like oh man the ball
that's so good it's so good I love it
but he was like a really great sport you
know I actually was standing next to one
my kid when John Williams is playing and
he was just like she's grinning ear to
hear you know in a nod to 40th
anniversary segment about it all I love
me yeah you know like there's there's
there's a version of that where he's an
[ __ ] about
yeah and internalize all the drubbing
that have come his way because of the
people's yeah and as a result is shitty
to the fans because of it yeah it's so
nice to hear that he's just like you
know what I'm a fan too like I made
these movies I love these movies they
changed my life yeah in fundamental ways
and why would I abuse anybody of their
love for it too
yeah he was super cool super cool yeah
you're right it's always great to see
that could very easily get the opposite
that's awesome and bad did I did I see
that go Dean Williams I have Billy Dee
was there he was there for the for the
40th anniversary panel yeah [ __ ]
Billy Dee was there you know is I mean
it Mark Hamill and Harrison Ford Billy
Dee work Davis who was another one of
the one of the hosts they're all on
stage together with George Lucas and
patty Kennedy and John Wayne's came out
and and Hayden Christensen's on stage
and the emperor in McDermott I mean they
were all there plus all the ILM guys in
the Skywalker Sound guys and behind the
scenes guys and my old school rebel
pilots were all there signing honors
within a panel with all of them
um so it was really cool you know
talking especially talking to some of
these old guy older guys who like we're
in the first movie and then suddenly
their phone rings like hey can you come
do a bit of looping and they don't know
why and I show up and they're in Rwanda
no idea right I think it's McGuiness was
like I didn't know what it was for and
then you know I went and saw the movie
and I was like holy [ __ ] like I had no
idea you know that was really really fun
to talk about that stuff so yeah there's
a lot of people that I mean Star Wars
lived there for four days it really did
the whole Star Wars universe is all
there they were all there Lucas Lucas
someone's probably ghost town at the
time that's amazing that's amazing I
love it's it's a concentrated version of
the thing that I love at comic-con which
is and I remember I came in when I was
talking to about this but the fact that
I've been that 15 or 16 Comic Cons in a
row and I've never been to a gathering
of that many people in the same place
yeah it did not in some way involve
violence like if you go if you go
football games you got a baseball game
if you go to a rally if you go to March
like there's always something that goes
wrong when there's that much passion
involved like nine times out of ten like
I can on one hand
the two times that I've heard of
somebody getting hurt in an altercation
at comic-con right and then you
concentrate that about one [ __ ] piece
of IP one giant Halcyon globe of wonder
of a pop culture yeah it's just a
beautiful thing to see it mainly is yeah
you're totally right yeah when you get
that many people together and everyone
just it's because they're all happy yeah
for the most part I mean people were
people were camping out all night
waiting for wristbands right the last
Jedi tractor ride Johnson like showed up
in the middle of the night and just said
hello to everybody that was camping out
and just sat there until everyone who
wanted an autograph or her selfie got
one that's awesome that's a kind of
goodwill is really cool you know in the
past they've brought Pete's like JJ
Abrams brought pizzas everybody you know
it's the holy SH it's right right
but yeah the demand was was crazy this
year it was really cool there's it's the
kid feeding the fanbase and that's why
they keep coming back that's right
right a lot more on the ride for sure
all right so let's talk about some of
the news the broke I oppose the biggest
shiniest thing was the first year the
last Jedi teaser yep um how did it play
in the room it was thought it was like
just the floor shaking you know I mean
everyone knew there'd be a trailer
anything right it was huge you know the
subwoofer was like pounding I mean it's
just it's so loud it's so big and it's
on this beautiful digital screen and you
know the room that I was in was thirty
one hundred plus seats so you had over
3,000 fans that are just kind of going
nuts for this thing and it's being
simultaneity you know I'm in another
theater plus I'm not on the web so like
you could just feel like you know the
energy in the room was just crazy
was there a tremor in the force there
was I was yes this is the thousand
voices cried out in absolute joy no it
was cool like I mean that the trailer
played really really well and of course
they roll it again and then we started
rolling it all weekend like clothes-wise
our monitor yeah yeah you know but the
bear leveland yeah exactly exactly yeah
yeah well the panel was canceled so
we're just going to play the teaser
trailer about the 50% for the hour
we're very okay does everyone fine with
that yes
they're fine with that but yeah it was
like to be in the actual room where it
debuted and with the cast on stage and
the director and you know cast members
returning new cast members all of that
really really cool yeah I mean it's it's
it i kevin gave his thoughts on a lesser
night
teaser on facebook live but you know for
me it's a it's a teacher like it does
what a teacher is supposed to do which
is not give me any story
I don't want story from a teaser like
all I kind of want are like incidental
pops of joy yeah kind of strung together
by music I recognize yeah and characters
that I remember a little like oh that's
right he got [ __ ] up and that's okay
and she's here and like it's basically
last week on Star Wars yeah that's what
a teacher kind of ought to be with a
little bit of like oh here's some new
[ __ ] that I had to seen before but we
set the table for me yeah but that's a
good point actually because in Anaheim
at celebration it wasn't a teaser it was
a like a bigger story trailer and I
always went with Han Solo sanctuary
where at home you know that whole thing
and that was like I mean you want it you
want to see grown men just shedding
tears I was there just there we were in
the room uh-huh
I mean it's just what he said we're home
and just like that's you know so but
this was a teaser right because we've
gotten a teaser for force awakens at
Thanksgiving you know around that time
in November in 2014
yeah something like that yeah but this
was like like you said it was just a
teaser yeah so there's so much more to
come we haven't even seen this was just
like a little totally like it I'd seen
some criticism online about people like
what this didn't give me anything that I
wanted it's like you know what sometimes
you're not supposed to get what you want
yeah I can that's fine like that's
that's how you build anticipation by not
giving a person what they want
yeah called tension and drama he said
it's not enough
spoilers like yeah you know you got to
find that balance like or pick one yeah
yeah like give me things that I haven't
seen before and then prickle the little
nostalgia zone in the back of my head
yeah and I'm totally fine with it I'll
need more than that yeah I mean that
that helicopter shot or whatever it was
of rage it's way out in the distance
with a lightsaber and man there's so
much cool stuff in that trailer
I mean you are already going through in
freeze-frame
and just like picking apart I mean the
internet the internet did what the
internet does when it was like here's
500 high-res Clips like snippets from a
two minute trailer yeah and what does
everything mean what is that what's that
supposed to be folks in a tree what's
the trees that the journal of wills life
happening yeah you know what we can ask
those questions and we can probably come
up with I guess fundamentally subjective
answers to this class but I don't care
yeah
don't answer them don't you I don't need
answers to get yeah it's like Luke
wearing a Jedi rover is that it's kind
of to his knees is that the more like a
Patagonia jacket like what is going on
there you know a bathrobe what is this
ain't always happens with with Star Wars
movies too is like you know a new Star
Wars movie there's actually did a panel
on rogue wanna music panel and you know
there's this thing that happens where
you're where you kind of have this fear
everyone has this I feel like it's
natural where you love something so much
that you can strangle it because you get
a new piece of it and you're you become
protective in a weird way and you're
like oh boy I don't know if I like this
I think I do I like this I think I kind
of do I don't know I don't know oh it's
good oh this is good oh I like this okay
all right hey all that was badass oh
this is really good
okay cool except for just one thing they
did yeah did bother you - yeah it
bothered me - yeah and then that's just
you know this thing is just really
bugging me that was not the right choice
they should have done this let's go to
coffee and talk about this actually you
know what this is [ __ ] I can't
believe they did that thing I can't
believe you're going to see it again
yeah like two more times tonight but it
doesn't you know like people are still
obsessing over it and then fast forward
like 10 years later and they're like
that's the best one yeah that's the best
movie of all I mean that is just that
there's a fan cycle of life that is the
circle of life and how it works and I am
as guilty of that as anybody because
it's what we do is how we live it's it's
it's the joy we get out of this stuff is
overanalyzing to the point of exhaustion
and then surrendering to it anyway yeah
yeah and I'm totally fine with that yeah
I live my life over elevation and
surrender it's part of the fun of it
honest yeah is just it's like endlessly
talking about it you know we brought up
the prequels before I will tell you
there's not a movie that I have spoken
about more than the Phantom Menace that
we have talked about more for better or
for worse such you know it is a gift
just in terms of something for geeks
like us to talk about you know at
like I mean this is give us the FATA
minutes and we will pick it apart right
like you know this even love it when you
love something or you are passionately
you know even if you hate something it
still be a lot of fun yeah you know I've
liked Emily and we we in the fat man
cave and the fat cave like to come at
things with a place of love like I go
into every movie wanting it to be good
oh yeah because life would be a [ __ ]
show if you wanted things could be bad
yeah I don't want to have to complain
about [ __ ] like I'm just please be
awesome just just surrender just [ __ ]
pummel me with awesome yeah well if it
isn't if it isn't obvious like I'm a
prequel defender only in that George
Lucas's is my hero and you know those
movies are not for everyone but they are
magical in very specific ways and I do
come at them with love too but yeah
they're great they're great topics of
conversation I love Star Wars but you
know I try not to have blinders on but
at the same time it's hard not to love
something like a podrace or episode 3
which i think is just a brilliant movie
through Jedi fighting with lightsabers
in volcano pretty cool hey and maybe
I'll get hate for it but whatever you
know all right
oh my god let it just roll up your ass
right that's right that's right okay so
also out of out of celebration we
learned that Carrie Fisher will not and
has had been previously reported by her
brother appearing in episode 9 right
from elbow it dude apparently her
passing sparked a massive overhaul of
whatever zone I was going to be right
you can see how it wouldn't any time the
core cast member right yeah I mean even
insurance and all I mean there's all
kinds of contingencies in production
when you have a plan and you work years
in advance you have to etch of it I mean
Lucas Dom's got a story group that just
does well yeah you know this is very
very cool right so that you know the
story group had to jump into action I'm
sure and and change a whole bunch of
stuff what that what that is well we'll
never know but I do remember there being
an announcement from Lucas snomed you
know squashing the rumor that they would
do sort of a digital layout like they
did for road one and and the digital
Leia was something that they showed her
and got her approval for the give her
special thanks you know at the end of
the credits so but yeah we dispelled
that rumor but
obviously she's an episode 8 she looks
gorgeous in Episode eight I know I did i
super dug I felt like there's a one shot
of her in the teaser way she's just
backlit and she's against yeah and she's
gotta hand it looks like Vader helmet II
yeah yeah yeah totally yes actually I
didn't even think about that that's
really true and now I'm thinking it if
you go back and watch the panel which is
you know which is online there's a still
of ryan johnson directing her and you
can see where the camera setup is that
was in that trailer shot and you can see
her face really really clearly in that
still and she looks amazing just so
regal and awesome yeah awesome and yeah
it's it's so and you know you know for
sure that the plan was always going to
be that that she would play it into a
part of nine yeah because you don't you
don't reintroduce Luke and Leia and not
have that their story come to some
natural conclusion in the last episode
of this nine part saga right yeah there
will be a Star Wars 43 at some point
because Disney and Lucasfilm we're never
to leave that money on the data yeah but
but this this chunk that we can still
sort of say that Lucas had envisioned
all along and was going to do story the
Skywalker family and she's as interval a
part of that family as anybody yeah yeah
so c'est la vie but new characters have
shown up yeah yeah that's true
welcome to the segue everybody uh Rose
played by an actress named Kelly Marie
Tran role Rose rose did you swim Jack
Jack know where Jack rose Shaq take a
shot every single time not last two
reels at least once the ship starts
leaking sorry
Jack and Rose sorry you were saying oh
good it's all good quotes from her from
the stage where my character's name is
rose as we just established she's a part
of resistance and she works in
maintenance so garbage lady is going to
save the universe which awesome I can't
wait for you to meet her according to
ryan johnson roses low-rank in the
resistance as part of her appeal this
possibility that any of us could step up
and become a hero that's what Rose comes
from what was uh did you get a chance to
meet her at all Indian I did not I just
I was there in the room for that panel
which was hosted by Josh GAD which by
the way was hilarious she's like so now
that I've got you here Daisy Ridley
is is Reyes Skywalker is Raya Kenobi
it's like me saying hi my name my whole
name is Josh you know to be nice to meet
you you know it was like that kind of
thing but just got nowhere with Daisy
Ridley but you know all we got from
telling return was was an introduction
of her a production still what a
character looked like in that
description and that was pretty much it
that's pretty much it
but mystery this idea that she plays a
they said something about her playing a
very key role in the adventure that she
ends up you know kind of almost
mistakenly perhaps me when reading into
this ends up on some kind of adventure
with the rest of the crew but I'm not
really sure but yeah I mean the picture
she looked really cool don't know yeah I
mean I'm just now hoping that there's
another trash come back to seeing now
that we have a maintenance worker on the
team well you know Finn Finn was also
you know he has that lining and Harrison
Ford like sanitation that's not how the
force works you know yeah so there's no
there's a lot of maintenance heroes but
a lot of custodial engineer yeah I don't
know but it's really cool the idea that
any anyone that here is come from
everywhere I mean that's the cold core
of Star Wars well you can be you know
you can be a farmhand or fit orphan who
raised by your aunt and uncle and you
can save the galaxy like that's the
whole whole idea so I'm curious to see
where they're going to go with that and
kind of excited that the second
installment has this whole new character
that we know nothing about that's
awesome that's awesome yeah and a female
character to boot which and as as we've
as we've counted sort of behold what the
Star Wars universe means to people it
means an incredible amount to young
women and old women and made middle-aged
women and girls you know I have a friend
who I've known for about thirty years
and we reconnected recently because I
knew her when I was a kid and I
reconnected with her through Star Wars
not even realizing it was her just being
part of the fan community and Twitter or
whatever and I I suddenly realize it was
her and we surprised each other it was
one of those you know and she's a little
older than I am and I mentioned that
when my niece's were there and one day
they were all aggressive Leia but
another day they were all she walks
ona Yoda bright
so she saw them and she just was like
you have no idea how this makes me feel
because when I was growing up all they
had were t-shirts for boys and it was
weird because when we reconnect I said I
had no idea you were Star Wars fan
because you know this is back in the 80s
when you know I was a little in whatever
but she's like well I didn't talk about
it back then because I didn't feel like
I could and you know we didn't have the
internet so it's not like we could you
know connected people you know and now
it's just I mean heard universe
everything that Ashley X mines done yeah
I know the costuming the characters you
know it's it's it really said it should
be late so it's truly for everybody you
know and and that's that's that's really
neat to see it in person too
you know when you see the whole family
all going together and they all have a
character that they're gravitating
towards you know that heroes come in all
shapes and sizes and and you know
different species and stuff like that I
mean that's that's just it's badass
totally you know and I think that's what
makes you know people have that sort of
sense of love over the weekend you know
no one's breaking out 50 cops or
anything yeah and like Lucasfilm was
leaning into that in a big way without
the forces of destiny
yeah yeah I got a D is that episode is
that episode on line they showed one did
they I don't think they put one up yeah
they showed one in the heroines panel
they showed one with Rey and it was
really cool you know like classic kind
of 2d looking animations and you know
Daisy Ridley I think was doing the voice
and all the classic sound yeah I mean oh
it's a series of YouTube shorts and a
two-part Disney Channel event like
they're actually going to put the stuff
on the television and it's all focused
on the female heroes of Star Wars so
it's Princess Leia rage a nurse ahsoka
tano Sabine Wren and they're narrated by
Maz Kanata she sort of had she's
stitching all of these stories together
and yeah they got Daisy relieved they
got Felicity Jones Lupita Nyong'o
they're all reprising their roles and
it's amazing yeah I mean it looks it
looks really really cool I mean that was
I couldn't be there at that panel but I
was there and tech rehearsal I got to
watch the run data just like oh my god
this is kind of huge yeah you know I
mean even obviously their YouTube shorts
but like more content please I mean just
just give us just give us more and it's
nice to be able to do this kind of like
you know it's not like a series with a
narrative that goes through episode of
episode instead you can go back and not
have to worry about continuity between
say she and I are so and Padma you know
or right or Rey and Leia you can just
kind of have these little little micro
adventures and watch something awesome
for a few minutes yeah she's a give me
an anthology Star Wars show yeah like
why not why is there an anthology
everything show yeah that's a good idea
just drop in absolutely for like four
five ten minute adventures and
characters and worlds that I love like
why the [ __ ] not yeah I mean yeah go
back to the way the way original Star
Trek was or Twilight Zone laws IV a
self-contained little Star Wars episodes
you don't have to have these sort of
like narratives I mean those are
satisfying it's wholly different way
anybody you can have both yeah that
would be cool yeah I'm good so as we're
seeing forces destiny sort of take its
place in the stage we're also going to
be seeing the end the Star Wars rebels
but then fourth season upcoming will be
its last I hosted that town house I was
on stage with Freddie Prinze jr. and
Dave Filoni and and all the really
talented voice actors and I knew that he
was going to make that announcement um
you know but it's really interesting
because he made it pretty clear that
this was about sort of ending things on
their own terms and being true to Star
Wars you know because the closer they
get to a new hope you know the more
they're kind of flirting with those that
continuity a little bit you know and and
so imagine what you can do in a fourth
season when you know it's your last
suddenly you don't have the Clone Wars
problem or the relative problem you know
countless show the Firefly problem
countless shows it just never got to
Firefly got a movie that was awesome but
you know like but yeah it got to wrap
themselves up you know and in a way
rebels has incorporated so many Clone
Wars characters you know Darth Maul and
racks and ahsoka and all that that that
you know saying alright this is the end
what a great creative I don't know what
a great creative choice that is and I'm
sure you know I mean Dave long he's so
talented and I've got a whole crew up at
Lucasfilm animation there's so much
muscle there to make something great
that you know I'm sure that we can
expect great things beautiful yeah I
mean that was the vibe that I got
yeah looking at some of the content was
this was not the last time Dave would be
doing a Star Wars animated project no no
that III could I don't know I mean maybe
I'm naive but I just couldn't you know
that guy that guy was George's Padawan
you know he got the dolly he fully got
the download Wow you know I remember
even as early as 2010 I was walking with
him through rehearsals and pick up the
cell phone and you're sucking and they
started doing show notes and he was like
I'm serious and I was like a
cottage-like he's like yeah what are
people people to say if they do I had
George Lucas on my cell phone but he did
you know he was he was working with him
every week and you know can be sort of a
real continuation in that legacy that's
all yeah he's too valuable to go
anywhere fantastic and tell me about the
the Battlefront to stuff oh yeah oh my
god that the whole the room just like
screamed you know the video game crowd
came out and I loved Allen I worked on
battlefront a little bit and of course I
worked on the originals Mozart's days
and you know there's a really strong
legacy there of multiplayer there was
some single player in the originals but
the big news for this one is that
they're telling an original story it
takes place right at the end of Return
of the Jedi and what's cool about it is
that they're telling the story from an
imperial point of view that if there's
this character named itom versio and she
grew up on a planet that was under
peaceful imperial reign like they liked
this you know they had a good economy
and everything was like clean you know
and imagine growing up thinking the
empire are the good guys and she grew up
in a military family and she was part of
the Empire and you know of course
they're making it from a soldiers
perspective that can fly in vehicles and
also do you know ground assault and
things like that you know in inferno
squad so like they're telling this
single-player story you know all the
motion captures out you know the actors
were sitting in the front row and was
super emotional when you know she's got
a call-out from luteum everything and
everyone's here but like they're going
for it you know and plus they're
bringing in all the characters from all
eras into multiplayer so like they're
just there's three Studios working on it
from what I can you know from what I got
from them you know there's criterion and
motive and yeah dice like the worldwide
thing
enormous enormous equal to the
battlefront so yeah I mean that was like
that was a really really big reveal you
know that's awesome I was really happy
for those guys because you know game
development they work their asses off
and years and years and years yeah yeah
years and years and years for sure so
that should be pretty amazing and it
comes out this fall that's all for the
last Jedi so okay so with Star Wars
Celebration Orlando yeah behind this
when do we think we're going to get the
next pop of Star Wars awesome and what
do you think it's going to be um is a
comic-con do we get a good question um
how if I had to guess let's see we've
got the movie coming out in December I
think Comic Con is a pretty fair guess
um then we know that there's not a
celebration next year right and we've
got a movie coming out in December we've
got another movie to console one will be
coming out in May of 2018 and when Ryan
d23 d23 is this summer
right so d23 could be another war before
Comic Con thinks it might be d23 right
it might be d23 you know the I also did
at Disney parks panel you know all about
the big stars expansions are doing a
Disney night of Disney World and they
hinted at d23 being the next time
they're going to say something gotcha
I make sense you know 2:23 is growing
and and there it seems like they're just
putting more and more into it to make it
cooler and cooler all the time so I
would guess this summer she's like yeah
I know and do we think it's a young Han
Solo something or something I if I had
to guess based on the patterns I don't
think they're going to well no they have
to don't they they can't promote young
Han Solo in five months they have to do
a teaser for that before last Jedi's out
how do you think I mean I think I think
you could do a teaser at comic-con with
you 23 right um right you can do a full
trailer if you want to wait as long as
thor ragnarok like that feels like it's
a pretty good birth yeah for some giant
[ __ ] Disney Marvel jamjam and then
you started you know you know this next
February March right and I need it hard
but I think that that feels like it's a
decent ramped up taking advantage of all
of these births that they
- stuff - yeah but I mean you just know
the whole age crab would go [ __ ] nuts
if oh yeah yeah yeah
young Han and young Lando and the
Millennium Falcon oh yeah totally
nothing but tears and so you actually
think we'll get a teaser for that before
we get another last Jedi a good trailer
I think so because I guess you have to
kind of you have to overlap them they do
have to come do this don't think like
they're coming up so yeah close to each
other yeah bottom up or you could get a
story trailer at d23 and you can get the
Han Solo trailer at Comic Con true if
you wanted to if you would Disney and
you wanted yeah if you wanted to grace
us with more Star Wars which is always
fine yes we'll happily take all happily
take all the worst not just one not just
one yeah
so where's next for you what do you got
on the horizon next for me well let's
see in terms of in terms of Star Wars
you know my big thing this year if I'm
lucky enough to be asked back for for
the premiere I'll do that you know I was
lucky enough to do some some voiceover
in the last couple movies uh who knows
I'm always I always treat every time I
get to do something with Star Wars
potentially the last time because
there's so many talented people out
there you know that all want to be in it
but you know in terms of Star Wars I'm
hoping that you know something with West
Jedi will you know I'll try and stay
involved like it's not good very glum
and then yeah I mean for me as a voice
actor I just had I just had Voltron
season to come out I played a character
in that I had some anime come out last
year series called one punch man and I
did and still just writing music mixing
a bunch of trailers it's what I do
terms of hosting I don't know I mean I I
literally got back from cut from Orlando
yesterday so I'm a little tongue-tied to
be honest with you isn't that enough
what Lord is underneath no no I I'm just
I would I would do it every weekend if I
could my body would fall apart but I
mean it was really really fun I was I
was sad that it was over my feet were
not but I was really I was I was having
that post-show blues so yeah thanks for
having me on it's helping Oh every year
I go to Comic Con
it is my brain still feels like it's the
first year yeah my brain is still it
like
when you years old but my spine and my
life
my knees are 45 and my breath back is
like oh you wanted to move you know
ya back fuses solid knees turn to powder
and like ah that's right you can't do
this like 728 at all I know I Drive body
I know yeah well I'm still 18 up here
it's the weirdest thing but uh but yeah
I mean in a way I'm just kind of happy
to see what what unfolds next with Star
Wars and I kind of like not knowing at
this point because it's still exciting
after all this time and I hope that that
excitement continues forever with with
that with that brand because I'm just my
first move that's awesome so where can
people find you on the Internet
probably the easy places at Twitter or
at Twitter go to add Twitter at David W
Collins on Twitter or Instagram is
probably the best but very cool well
dude thank you there's nothing by the
back yeah thank you so much on giving us
all the inside dope yeah that is it for
this episode of fat man on Batman I have
been mark Bernard Lee this is David
calling you find us in SModcast calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith see you
soon
[Music]
you
[Music]